[Music]
you could have been killed your flight
to L.A leaves in 45 minutes talking
about how to stay in Bel Air with your
aunt and your uncle well oh I was so
happy you're here
I got accepted into an influencer house
so I'm gonna be living with other social
media concerts we clear out kylo and we
Rebrand as this female forward space
we decided that we want to offer you the
following
Fellowship always
been enamored with your work want to use
my platform to
discover new Talent
so I have this friend
that I have a question
have a name
Lucia are you surprised no
I'm not surprised that you're gay I'll
always be here if you ever need to talk
[Music]
you are the only black candidate that's
running for district attorney correct
yes yes I am not everyone liked the
comments you made about law enforcement
Fred Wilkes knows about Will's arrest
and the strings he pulled to get him out
of trouble today I'm withdrawing from
the race to be the next district
attorney
I'm trying to keep whatever this is
going for as long as possible yo
well what up yo Jazz can you put Hillary
on the phone I don't know what you're
talking about why why would I be with
Hillary
will was arrested after a fight
Philadelphia there was a gun involved
tell me this isn't you will
you lied to me about who you really are
and why you're here
I feel like I don't know the first thing
about you
man
I'm sorry for the I put you
through being treated like this
sucks
it's okay man I'll sweating
[Music]
he's not someone will lose in his life
right now I asked you not to and he used
my behind my back the boy has the right
to know because you feel guilty about
leaving your own boy behind sadly I
can't trust you anymore
you're fired
sup bro
to walk up in here and make all those
years of Lies disappeared
don't leave man I'm not staying here
another night hurt and confused but I
promise you we can fix this as a family
we are not a family you let me think my
dad abandoned me and I can't trust none
of you you told me
the city would try to make me forget who
I am and where I come from
and you're right
you got all these possibilities and
choices right in front of you
so you gotta make a choice
where do you want to go
[Music]